The Legend of Zelda tears of the kingdom
is so much more than a sequel to breath
of the wild while this newest entry in
the Zelda franchise is most recognizably
similar to that 2017 game it builds upon
the foundation so thoroughly and
transformationally that it feels like a
revelation this is the Legend of Zelda
at its finest borrowing the best pieces
and qualities from across the
franchise's history and creating
something new that is emotionally
resonant captivating and endlessly
rewarding
[Music]
tears of the Kingdom follows in its
predecessor's footsteps with a similarly
naturalistic setting but the world has
changed in subtle ways not everything is
exactly the same or where you'd expect
it to be and the map is marked with
Myriad opportunities for exploration and
curiosity Hyrule feels Serene even as it
bustles with life and activity the score
is as Majestic as it is unintrusive
accentuating a dire battle or narrow
escape with an exciting up-tempo
rendition of the theme and then easing
off with softer tones to let you breathe
in the atmosphere
[Music]
foreign
much of the reason that the world feels
so different this time is that your
tools for engaging with it are much more
flexible these abilities are the engine
that drives tears of the kingdom in the
same way breath of the wild was centered
on exploring Wilderness using your slate
of abilities these new tools Center
tears of the Kingdom around building and
experimenting to overcome obstacles in
inventive ways it's a beautifully
implemented evolution of what made
breath of the wild so special while it's
more ambitious than breath of the wild
and how much you can express your own
creativity it also manages to do this
without buckling under its own weight
the two most important abilities are
Ultra hand and fuse since they serve as
the cornerstones of exploration and
combat respectively Ultra hand lets you
piece together just about anything you
find including a vast array of new
building materials and ancient zonai
machine parts fuse lets you modify your
melee weapons arrows and shields by
attaching things to them in ways that
thematically similar to ultra hand the
two act as halves of the same hole
encouraging you to constantly try new
versions of a mind-boggling array of
combinations simply to see what happens
while fusing items does grant them extra
durability there's a deeper more
philosophical layer at play with how
these new systems interact durability in
breath of the wild was about scarcity
and resource management and tears of the
kingdom it feels more about pushing you
to try new combinations everything is a
toy and tears of the Kingdom wants you
to play with your toys smash them
together throw them around and find joy
and the unexpected results
foreign
the other two abilities granted in the
tutorial area recall and Ascend are more
limited in scope but still quite
important recall which rewinds objects
back to a previous state has both combat
and exploration applications letting you
easily toss a bomb back at some hapless
modeling or cleverly create yourself a
moving platform to cross a Chasm a sin
lets you swim upwards through solid rock
easily finding your way into hidden
rooms and quickly reaching spaces that
would have taken longer or been
impossible to manually climb
one more key ability is optional but
grows more important as you build an
array of machine parts and take on
tougher obstacles Auto build an
extension of the ultra hand ability
simply stitches together the requisite
parts for a design you either have saved
in your recent history or one that
you've marked as a favorite to save
permanently all of these building tools
and the ascendability effectively
de-emphasize your stamina meter for
climbing but the construction tools make
the game so vertically oriented that it
makes traversal flow naturally that's
also due to the sky view Towers which
serve not just as waypoints for filling
out the map but as cannons to launch you
far into the sky as you ascend you'll
reach another layer of the map where the
sky islands reside with their own
secrets to uncover
the sequence in which link launches into
the air is seamless rocketing into the
sky and then falling back to Earth feels
thrilling every time and you can use the
Vantage Point as you descend to float
towards the goal or look around for
undiscovered landmarks to my shock
ascending to the sky and then falling
back to Earth ran smoothly there has
been plenty of concern about the Aging
switch Hardware being adequate to run
tears of the Kingdom well and for my
part I barely ever saw hitch while
playing mostly in handheld mode in fact
the rare instance in which I did notice
a slight frame rate dip in both handheld
and dock modes wasn't during the big
grandiose moments like launching link
into the sky but rather a smaller Moment
Like exploring the bustling kakariko
Village during a rainstorm even then the
performance dips were minor and
temporary in docked mode it's easier to
spot a loss of some detail on Faraway
objects when flying high but the
painterly style obscures it well the map
is again littered with landmarks
especially shrines which serve double
duty as fast travel points alongside the
Skyview Towers the shrines are key to
upgrading your health and stamina and as
before these are quick snacks size
puzzle in combat rooms a new separate
consumable can also be used to upgrade
your portable battery pack so that your
zonai machines can run that much longer
and in the massive underground area you
can light your own way with bright Bloom
seats and activate special
bioluminescent plants that act as their
own fast travel points this separation
between three layers of the open world
each with its own vastly different
Ambiance makes exploration truly feel
like adventuring in a vast Uncharted
World these tools and the sprawling
World they inhabit gives tears of the
Kingdom a particular flow that feels
unique to the Zelda franchise you aren't
simply solving puzzles or fighting
battles your engineering Solutions you
might encounter a gap you can't cross a
fight you can't win or a puzzle you
can't solve but you know you have the
tools and you know where you can find
the materials and all that's left is to
put your plan into action if that plan
fails and sometimes it will
you tweak your plan and you try again
despite the incredible Freedom it's not
overwhelming while Creative Solutions
are encouraged and might make some
challenges much easier you can certainly
make it through the story using simpler
designs it rewards you for flexing your
creative muscles but it meets you where
you are the four major quadrants of the
map correspond to the four major
dungeons which this time are more
traditional than breath of the Wild's
Divine Beasts for one thing in a knowing
nod these ones are actually called
temples each named after an element like
wind or fire they are structurally
similar each revolving around a series
of locks in one way or another but they
are wildly different in style and tone
the Thunder Temple segues from an
Indiana Jones homage to an extremely
traditional Zelda dungeon complete with
mirror puzzles the wind Temple meanwhile
takes place in a floating Airship with a
dense overlapping structure there are
moments in each Temple that feel
audacious like nothing you've seen in a
Zelda game before all intermingled with
a style and presentation that will
please those who like me miss the
classic feeling Zelda dungeons in breath
of the wild you don't receive a special
item in each dungeon that corresponds to
its puzzle structure however instead
each dungeon features a companion
specific to one of the diverse races in
zeldalore like the Goron or Zora your
companion effectively grants you their
own power on demand for puzzle solving
in combat making it feel like you've
found a special item while also imbuing
it with character each of the four major
characters is lovable in their own way
with fantastic character design that
makes them stand out from their Brethren
combat is mostly de-emphasized in the
temples letting you focus squarely on
exploration and puzzle solving for most
of their duration that isn't the case
for the bosses though which are some of
the toughest I've seen in any Zelda game
these ferocious beasts are there to put
your skills to the test and more than
once I had to leave a engine entirely to
better prepare I was glad to see the
tears of the Kingdom allows for that and
even counts on it letting you fast
travel out of a dungeon to spend time
elsewhere and then easily pick a battle
back up when you fast travel back to the
closest Waypoint the one drawback of
this open structure is that your special
abilities can be counted on to stack on
each other since tears of the Kingdom
lets you play Dungeons in any order the
puzzles can only be structured around
one key ability at a time tears of the
Kingdom's story is my favorite aspect of
the game and it is absolutely my
favorite Zelda story in years it begins
as Zelda and Link investigate a blight
named the Gloom that seems to be
emanating from underneath Hyrule Castle
in an uncharacteristically creepy touch
the two find a desiccated corpse
immediately recognizable to Zelda fans
as Ganondorf being held down by a
glowing disembodied arm
Ganondorf snaps back to life wounds link
and breaks the master sword in the
ensuing chaos Zelda falls into Inky
Blackness and when link awakens she's
nowhere to be found in place of his
right arm is the one that was found
holding Ganondorf The Story Goes On to
explain that ages ago the first king of
Hyrule United the sages representatives
of each race of Hyrule against an army
of the Demon King Ganondorf now with
your new arm you have the power to
reunite the sages and tap their powers
leading to your cross-country Trek to
find those with their bloodlines who can
fulfill the pacts their ancestors made a
millennia ago each of these new sages
grapples with their responsibility in
their own way which makes each Temple
its own small character story with their
own individual payoffs the world of
Tears of the kingdom is one in which
diversity is a strength built on the
backs of individuals brave enough to
work for a collective good there's a
palpable sense of weight as each of them
except the mantle some more hesitantly
than others they're some of the
strongest tertiary characters in Zelda
history imminently lovable and Humane
people who each drive home the themes of
collective responsibility and the weight
of heroism in different ways
but more than the sages or even link
this story truly belongs to Zelda your
main quest both in terms of the story
and literally in your quest log is to
find Zelda there's a through line of
mystery to the whole affair with
scattered reports of Zelda sightings
across the kingdom discovering where
she's gone is told in a non-sequential
manner with the mystery slowly
unraveling toward an incredible stirring
Revelation there's a specific moment in
this story that will go down as one of
the most memorable in all of Zelda Canon
when I think of the Legend of Zelda
series I've always thought about
Transcendent Mythic moments pulling the
master sword from the pedestal in A Link
to the Past waking the wind fish and
Link's Awakening the three major
characters representing aspects of the
Triforce in Ocarina of Time tears of the
Kingdom has a woman that matches each of
those and I felt the scope and power of
it so strongly that I shed my own tears
as much as I loved each of those pieces
in Zelda's past I'm not sure if it's
ever evoked that level of motion in me
before
and then of course there's the story you
write yourself through gameplay when you
built a clever machine to cross a Chasm
explored a dark Cavern with only your
wits and a handful of arrows raced
through a thunderstorm on Horseback to
find shelter Zelda tears of the kingdom
is a canvas for your own creativity a
book to write your own stories a world
to create your own Legends it gives you
back as much as you put into it and it
beckons you to soar burrow engineer
solve adventure and explore
foreign
[Music]